there are responsible pet owners but
it's just idiots like this that just
ruin it for everybody you should kill
the owner
dog kill somebody they should kill you
you want to kill this guy we got glasses
dude attacks
Lasik I wear glasses
to someone else they gotta do that to
you yeah so if your dog licks your
neighbor's dick you gotta make your
neighbors it's only right I'm gonna
provoke the [__] in my neighbor's dog 50
of dog owners probably should not have
dogs like because they're not
responsible they don't train their dogs
look at your ring camera the app and you
see all these people losing their dogs
constantly like already people in their
mindset with dogs is like I don't give a
[__] it's a pet whatever so it's like if
you're gonna have a dog you can't have
that mindset so it's on you it's you are
the owner so you should go to [__]
jail damn jail passionate